prolonged space travel takes a severe
toll on the human body microgravity
impairs muscle and bone growth and high
doses of radiation caused irreversible
mutations as we seriously consider the
human species becoming spacefaring a big
question stands even if we break free
from Earth's orbit and embark on
long-duration journeys among the stars
can we adapt to the extreme environments
of space this won't be the first time
that humans have adapted to harsh
environments and evolved superhuman
capabilities not fantastical powers like
laser vision or invisibility but
physiological adaptations for survival
in tough conditions for example on the
Himalayan mountains where the highest
elevation is 9 kilometres above sea
level an unexperienced intima poxy a--
commonly known as mountain sickness at
these altitudes the body usually
produces extra red blood cells
thickening the blood and impeding its
flow but Himalayans who have lived on
these mountains for thousands of years
permanently evolved mechanisms to
circumvent this process and maintain
normal blood flow cases like that prove
that humans can develop permanent
life-saving traits but natural
adaptation for entire human populations
could take tens of thousands of years
recent scientific advances may help us
accelerate human adaptation to single
generations to thrive as a species
during space travel we could potentially
develop methods to quickly program
protective abilities into ourselves a
beta version of these methods is gene
therapy which we can currently use to
correct genetic diseases gene editing
technology which is improving rapidly
allows scientists to directly change the
human genome to stop undesirable
processes or make helpful substances
an example of an unwanted process is
what happens when our bodies are exposed
to ionizing radiation without an
atmospheric barrier and a magnetic field
like Earth's most planets and moons are
bombarded with these dangerous subatomic
particles they can pass through nearly
anything and would cause potentially
cancerous DNA damage to space explorers
but what if we could turn the tables on
radiation human skin produces a pigment
called melanin that protects us from the
filtered radiation on earth melanin
exists in many forms across species and
some melanin expressing fungi used the
pigment to convert radiation into
chemical energy instead of trying to
shield the human body or rapidly repair
damage we could potentially engineer
humans to adopt and express these fungal
melanin based energy harvesting systems
they then convert radiation into useful
energy while protecting our DNA this
sounds pretty sci-fi but may actually be
achievable with current technology but
technology isn't the only obstacle there
are ongoing debates on the consequences
and ethics of such radical alterations
to our genetic fabric
besides radiation variation in
gravitational strength is another
challenge for space travelers until we
develop artificial gravity in a
spaceship or on another planet we should
assume that astronauts will spend time
living in microgravity on earth human
bone and muscle custodial cells respond
to the stress of gravity's incessant
tugging by renewing old cells in
processes known as remodeling and
regeneration but in a microgravity
environment like Mars human bone and
muscle cells won't get these cues
resulting in osteoporosis and muscle
atrophy so how could we provide an
artificial signal for cells to
counteract bone and muscle loss again
this is speculative but biochemically
engineered microbes inside our bodies
could churn out bone and muscle
remodeling signaling factors or humans
could be genetically engineered to
produce more of these signals in the
absence of gravity radiation exposure
and microgravity are only
two of the many challenges we will
encounter in the hostile conditions of
space but if we're epically prepared to
use them gene-editing and microbial
engineering are two flexible tools that
could be adapted to many scenarios in
the near future we may decide to further
develop and tune these genetic tools for
the harsh realities of space living
Oh